hey everybody Welcome to multiple
players H I'm your host Chris Waters
this Wiggly guy next to me is Rob
Handler we got Tom McShay on the end
here and Shawn mcginness a Full Slate
four for Golden ey7 on the N64 uh it's
video game history month we want to you
know celebrate the games of our past
we've all played this game extensively
in the past but in the preliminary
rounds we've been playing what we've
come to DET terine is that some of us
remembered better than others Chris
doesn't remember it at all which is to
say I remembered very poorly Chris is
like how do you reload yes so this will
be fun yeah it's GNA be real we should
point out that Rob Rob hold up your
handicap Oh I thought I was going to
okay oh my goodness he has a piece of
art right here what is the what is the
company that we can defame make Pad 64
now we all have like official Nintendo
controllers whereas this guy has
unofficial controller I'll take one for
the team I don't make cry here perfect
handicap Salvador Dolly made a
controller it's actually pretty good
little art reference so the way we're
going to do it is what the person who
gets first is stuck with that I think
that's we're going to switch it around
decent way to go so yeah so we're going
to start things off with Sean Sean is in
control of this so expect a lot of let's
go with automatics for now uh we are
going to go who chooses all right
everybody pick a
character no yes all right so
I am going to be you guys all have no
class you got to choose a named
character or get the hell out even if it
had even if he has a bright
blouse I'll choose a named character
you're going to choose odd job we all
know what's going to happen I'm not
going to choose odd job I'm going to
choose should I pick Baron s
Amigo you got snaked on the baron
Michigan M
I'm going to play May I am Invincible
all right Sean should you just go Bond
or are you more of a travelan Sean Bean
yep I think he might die he'll die he'll
die so are you the only one who doesn't
have the courage to pick a named
character well I also have this um piece
of crap right here do you want to do
power weapons true again the trigger
finger which is s normal no I'm going
with the middle finger that's what this
controller makes me use it's like if
someone took uh the two parallel prongs
of an N64 controller and then put them a
skew like this in order to play like but
then if you want to hold it normally you
have to middle finger the trigger it's
it looks real uncomfortable a feels wor
what does ohmss mean off Majesty Secret
Service Mission God you're probably
right uh it's totally it yeah all right
actually never notic that Let's do let's
do a video that either after how many
hours all right I'm up right all right I
I'm bottom left I'm I'm bottom right
dd44 by process of elimination that
means I'm top
left that's how Shawn determines all of
his
shotgun that's why we're doing Auto oh
no yeah Auto we're doing power weapons
oh power weapons which is oh what's up I
love the way you look what up Natalia oh
no I only got the one bullet slap time
oh slap fight slap fight come here get
get get slapped get slapped come on come
on this is the first place to be in the
middle of a fight when I don't have my
gun why am I slapping Jillian Anderson
her name is Gillian we got ourselves we
got God brought a
gun I'm so sorry that was a real shitty
move okay you know what I'm going to
teach you a lesson dude your one slap
took off like all my armor yeah that's a
nice my slap is a power weapon it's a
nice backhand you have there Sean thank
you this is getting aw I could have
sworn there was a gun up here damn it
someone already took it who's just I
need a freaking gun oh no you got the
body armor come on get r
I know that noise that is oh does
somebody already have a P90 oh that's
already like like you like you can't get
it right away well I mean you know
that's like the best that's the best gun
yeah there's no you what the name was
based on P90 damn right no it was based
off of the r processing chip in the N64
that had that moved that fast well like
I know all of the gun names are just
slight changes from like yeah the
exactly the one that I have here the
automatic one is based off of the risk
processing chip in the system and the is
based off a Ken lob like actual gun in
real life called a P90 and slightly
changed and it looks very similar to
that you're talking about the pistol no
P90 okay somebody in the chat's going to
have to verify rc9 cuz someone's going
to have to the one I have someone's
going to ver you guys on the right side
that's an rcp90 agreed yeah it's
official that's official I know what I
know it is I'm just saying that based on
where it name is so they added the r as
a reference to that thing you were
talking about Sean b this is the second
time I've seen you run around with no
weapons like you get into battle with
nothing I'm [__] Boromir I'll slap
the [__] out of you you do have a mean
slap come on get slapped get slapped who
no oh my God this might be the enemy I'm
going run away and get a gun no no
getting a gun where are you shotgun I
know you're still oh my God why is there
let's see are you in
here no no no I'm not in any maybe this
one no oh what am I doing opening I'll
just shoot him up you just no n Only is
that you'll run out of this is not a
good fight for me to be in I hope you're
oh no D Coming St oh huis H that was a
cleanway too close so who the heck am I
I'm Mayday do you know what this is
MayDay I don't I familiar with what
movie that would be oh come
on oh the speed of the shotgun why have
I not found a gun yet was how do I find
a there I think there's one back in that
bathroom damn there's you oh [__] you
are such a you are such a jerk my hand
is a power my God come on where are
you you're getting BL oh you're done
power weapon no oh yeah mopping it up oh
you know what Bo Sean I know you have a
black shirt on oh no wait I was going to
shoot his body oh sorry go ahead shoot
his body ah it's okay it's gone all
right fine I'll just kill you instead
yeah mopping up I got blood in my eyes
yeah you got you died from Blood In Your
Eyes e what that's what happens in the
game you don't die from gunshots yeah
you die from Blood In Your Eyes yeah you
die from Blood In Your Eyes real true
yeah get slapped get slapped Gillian
Anderson I will yes come Gillian
Anderson know Gillian it's definitely
Gillian all I know is that that
character looks like Skully hello you're
totally right I
know oh get it oh shoot in the head oh
hey what's up guys rcp90
party
no up the uh dang it action
here oh no shotgun no so close I love
the intense breathing of getting shot
with an
AR where's my where's my
inhaler oh yeah some hang out in the
bathroom shooting an elevated
situation aiming up and down with a SE
stick stop it stop it that's fun right
go away from me go away from where I am
aiming with the SE buns that's fun oh
man no where did you come from who are
you why why would they I'm just going to
hose down this hallway and hope for the
best you just got a r P90X out I
recommend not using the hallway today
guys that was a good Fitness joke Sean
yeah pretty good huh topical right
everybody's always working out
everyone's always working out everyone's
always for some good work I'm getting
shot so much I can't turn the corner
because Rob's a jerk oh no I'm out of my
P90 yeah you're out of your P90X workout
I hit that damn J gun everybody shooting
me oh it's so hard to aim at anything
uhoh am I getting flanked here
do just why won't you die why don't you
die you're like a
phoenix why is there someone else here
I've only got a DV oh I wanted to hang
out jeez a phoenix a phoenix dies did
you win oh did I win let's check that'd
be embarrassing think Rob won he did I
got second Chris got third and got look
at that shortest Innings Mark once again
I got most dishonorable that's the only
way to play if you're not dishonorable
then what are you
cowardly that's all you got yeah unarmed
and cowardly is Honorable like when you
don't shoot somebody when they're
unarmed or you don't shoot them in the
back is that how that works what's the
criteria there I think it's I don't know
maybe it has to do with hanging out in
the bathroom for long per he uses the
n64's e sensor to sense your emotions
and the emotional truth about you and
then analyze super does anyone want to
do bement proximity mines yes absolutely
are we we jumping straight to that sure
let's do it I mean okay so since I did
win I have to keep keep going on this
guy you guys you have to stay with your
demented malform have you s situations
for what so that I can make it better I
can put you guys in your screen sh all
right Bonito wants us to switch seats so
that we are needs to go to the end here
why I'm top left no no but don't wor
don't question it it's it's going to be
great I like this idea you where am I
Rob goes where Sean is and then you just
SC be tough microphon Chris doesn't move
at all I have a feeling we're tangling
all of this stuve the
controllers sorry you guys get to see
this live look at me I don't on the AR
it's just going to be shuffled look at
this not going to
see what happened to Sean's head it's
gone also you look like you're like
hanging back there like some of mar cuz
you're standing on something what did
you think it was I just said what it
looked like Tom I was
using visual language no don't sit on it
but I'm not going to move
it my microphone situation is boned just
I'm so far from my corner of the screen
too oh go B it's going to look great
guys your eyes literally have to look a
foot or two further how can we at least
move the TV to the right Bonito no just
look over there with your goddamn eyes
it's so much farther away I lose so much
Fidelity you're right the light takes a
longer time to reach your eyeballs your
butt is definitely inside of my butt
right that happened Famous Last Words
famous last words oh my God move oh my
god oh I was not expecting that butt can
breathe again walk right in here come on
come on there over whoa I see you thr
those proximity
mines oh no I blew
myself that got
this look at how it's working oh my God
Bonito is a magician he a magician I
take everything I said about you B who
what did you say about bonit get out of
here get your hand out of here I was
spreading some salacious rumors about
him were they true rumors or fake rumors
I don't know [__] they were true lives
everything about me dying is bad guys
who decided to do proximity mines on the
basement I love prox basement it's the
best but it's how you have any health
left you have no Health you're literally
just body armor it's called body armor
and it helps all right I'm going to rig
myself a little security room how did
you oh my God my my God there's so much
fire and death oh my God no the huge
mity oh that amazing I trying to do that
to you you know what happened I went
there too quickly I
panicked just like jod Foster in that
one movie Flight 97 flight 97 oh [__] A
G Denzel Washington I know drunk flying
pilot Guy what's that movie called
flight
yeah audiences don't want to see flying
pilot guy we need a better name yeah
what if we just shortened it to Pilot
guy no no what about the other part of
the title okay this room got God damn it
in the head come on who came in here
with proximity mines what you're
trying [__] oh my God what the
did I win I think Sean just won shoot I
think I just won again was it from when
I rigged up that Panic oh my God you're
down there not oh just kissed Sean oh my
God how did you you kill I was in a duel
with you you know what it might be this
controller guys that controller is op we
were all wrong on that controller yeah
that weird impressionist controller
award how do I get a what's leming award
again cuz you killed three people you
might have been one of those people no
that's triple I was one of those people
what's leming award uh
you kill yourself I think suicide a lot
all right all right so we're going to
do all
right do we do complex complex no yeah
do that definitely weapons do uh Rockets
are really good Rockets are
really you can shoot them through that
you can shoot them in
that
one the rest of the places it's going to
be terrible can you shoot Rockets out of
the vents of the
uh but you can totally show shoot them
in that hole someone step over there and
get cobbed I'm going to shoot a rocket
in a
hole good good plan is my favorite
pornographic film I'm going to shoot a
rocket in a hole part
two uhoh it's CL time
baby oh that was worth it that was worth
it clob damn you can lob I don't have
natural C I think Sean had nothing to do
with me
dying the clob is just the worst gun is
yeah of course I had to drop on Rob and
I cobbed him and then I died the clob is
notoriously awful it's supposed to be
because Ken lob was a funny man
apparently and they named a bad gun
after they just troll him it was a troll
because they liked him if they didn't
like him they would have just silently
sued and gotten angrier and angrier oh
Dam it I didn't see that damn it I was
really hoping you had gone oh I gu like
picked up a gun this time that
legitimately what are you doing here
jerk Sean Bean yeah my character has the
same name as I do and by character I
mean sha
Bean who were you playing as shanan
trellion Sha Bean oh my blank to to
Rob's head with a shotg or a rocket
launcher rocket to the Dome that's the
way to do it if I die then you die that
that'll kill that'll kill someone it'll
kill someone's and then it'll kill you
people die when you kill people die when
you kill who's up who's who's lower
right that's me oh you want to come up
here anyone used a rocket successfully
at all don't me do it I'll do it I'll do
it I successfully used a rocket no
choice nice this is what they do in like
the real war is they go and they go and
Catey chop people so they suicide oh
shoot if you I forgot Suicide takes off
a kill yeah but also you got a kill for
killing me so I'm you're back where you
started and back where I started uhoh
guys this match might take a long time
cuz I bumped it up to 10 oh you did yeah
that was probably a mistake what killed
you Chris what could it have been I
don't know explosions no it was fire is
it that's the same thing insanely longl
lasting Fireball I mean it was probably
the fire after the explosions would be
my oh you missed no you did I did I
missing did I really miss the answer's
okay you did Miss and then but then you
walked into the fire I walked into the
fireball have we mentioned that aiming
is not super easy in these in this game
aiming is the literal
worst it's how you got to you got to
lead Rob and hope that he walks into the
fire yeah there's something I haven't
seen another play walked out and the air
was filled with charge corpse smoke
there's like there's mad Auto from this
game or else it wouldn't really work the
best is when there's like two people in
the room I'm not getting into a club
fight again I won't do it where is any
player I who are you what player top
left I'll go get you right now I'm Shan
Bean I'm playing the character of sha
bean I will
die love that rocket
noise I love the uh intense music that's
myab rob you get your armor again dang
it got you Sean why do I keep moving to
the left and right are you shooting me
with bullets and my aim is moving that's
what it feels like I feel like your
shirt should red I am so bad at this
game I used to be so good at this game
uh kind of kind of a reflection of real
life huh yep like like how you're bad at
at life that's why I invite you guys on
this stream to take real low blows in my
self-esteem low blows oh let me just
multiple blows I'm it's getting sweaty
over here there's a fan blowing right on
my my sweat and do and throwing it under
your face I was talking about the heavy
panting that I was getting into with I
wanted to talk about how my sweat was
being blown what is what is the score
this is a disaster I know yeah is
anybody oh that means someone's real
close who's top right no it means he is
only halfway what was it to if he has
five how many times did you die Tom it's
like twice so I must have died like
eight times from suicide this is you
right Tom this is [__] there's
supposed to be a lot rocket launcher
involved in this fight yes run no R
run you sucker you're so bad at this
game that you just let me run by I'm
such a sucker uh Tom I won the last two
games don't you dare say that to me oh
get dead
G I ran away I didn't want you to kill
me this for an x
file I don't get it how was this for
[__] I died man totally totally lost me
man you got away from do so I have zero
points you got away from me this time
did people see how amazing that was what
I just did what did you just run away
yeah but he he congratulations most
cowardly no and I'm right here
don't do it don't you do it I'm just
going to disappear yes disappear under
this success come on yeah nothing
happens now oh oh [__] what do you mean
I got to kill you you died too who knew
that as a human body can pass through a
secret wall so can a bullet if I can get
20 kills on a 10 10 point match I will
be more than happy that will be
impressive I won't be more than happy be
less happy I'll be unhappy cuz I'm doing
real bad [__] oh that didn't work out
for you did
it got old launcher Del roetto that's a
fake up a fake madeup language for
rocket launcher [__] where is the rocket
launcher
on yeah that was good I'm impressed Tom
can every everything you say please just
be an incredulous repeating of how
idiotic you think the thing that I just
said was cuz you're doing pretty well so
far I think it's pretty cool that you
decided to play a game for the first
first time on the stream guty of you no
not again I'm not letting that happen oh
again Tom watch out there those Rockets
they're a little
tricky I like your style
Rob which is what it's very spiteful
very spiteful
wow like who just whoa L of smoke up in
this
bee hello oh hi how you doing it's cling
time look at look at our our uh rolls
are reversed now I have the clob and no
ammo oh no wait oh how'd you get up over
there where is Sea
hiding in here motherfucks uh uhoh uh uh
uh uh why is that so much grosser than
putting the at the end I don't know no
don't walk into who is the rocket Maniac
that just came in here I'm just going to
sit that one out God damn it all right
take a trip to rocket town and CH is
wondering why I wanted do rocket
launchers rocket launchers
oh [__] [__] is right hey hold off on
the Rockets just
wait a dam now who's the guy who's dead
it's you you are the guy who's choking
on blood a chance to answer what is
going on over there Ching on blood yeah
yeah whoa where' you come
from that was a real wild card move cool
I use my 10 bullets so this gun fight's
over all I see you later buddy I do
suicide hey guys I just want you to know
that we are actively losing progress
toward a winner we were at 5-2 now we're
3 yeah nobody has more than three points
this is my favorite we might have to
quit out of this no why would we quit
out never never you're right that was a
stupid idea oh no this is not going well
get
clob famous last no I didn't damn it I
had a health thing left did you kill
yourself shut up did you lose a point
you were I have nine
suicides do you even have any bullets no
I don't oh I don't oh my God you're
right no this is
alarming who's in the room that oh Jesus
no
bullets but now I have bullets this is a
dumb idea yes I didn't kill myself damn
it the greatest Triumph of all kill
count 12 I have 12 kills and nine
suicides seriously though where do you
get the rocket it's on the ramp in the
secret area and then in the lower area
on the other side yeah you know it's uh
in the upper area I don't know how to
describe that clearly it's in the room
with all the gray ah you got spawn I
mean Sean's where the other where one of
them is it's in the gray room the other
one is where Rob is or lower left that's
where you are right down there all right
I found one no thanks to any of you
dummies I tried to help you I can't help
I really appreciate you trying to help
me even if you did a terrible job of it
[__] you killed yourself you killed
yourself I'm going to go up there go up
there I don't like this what do you like
though do you like sausage did you just
kill
yourself wait are you still alive you
got me there all right now it's my turn
no ST oh God is there a certain Special
Forces around here yes oh you and your
oh sh again
again that's a third time you literally
no Health look at your health no it's
literally zero that I'm aware it's just
dumb if I didn't kill myself 10 times I
don't know how to finish that sentence
and make I mean that's bad that's a bad
way to start a
sentence who shooting through that
window that's not going do anything I
was trying I was trying a gun move the
best way to play golden eye is to both
play and then critique everybody else
while you're playing yeah that's true
that's very you're not critiquing then
you're not even trying and you're not
learning either you know yeah
exactly we're not yeah not learning or
critiquing I'm just failing uhoh and
getting Saad W hey really threaded the
needle on that one that was a really
good shot wasn't it that was a good shot
I didn't even use the hey how come
nobody has gained any points in the last
four minutes I suicide more often than I
don't
suicide uh oh this is it right here
[__] did you kill me or did I suicide
you suicided shut up I ran away from I
have 11
suicides why do you have so many
suicides oh that's a double that's a
double you lost a point there no he was
up I he was killed one of you guys yo
you got a double kill
might run up run yes I made it up all
right new kill limit is six we were
playing to the end whoever reaches six
points ohing we're close we're close
we're
close no wait this is it we're so close
Chris what are you doing I'm literally
going to I think I think this might be
forever it is it's oh my
God he he's got seven kills I'm so close
all so
close Rob where guys it hurts to hold an
N64 controller Rob I'm standing in a wi
I'm literally damn it get like this is
not
ergonomic oh I can't believe that I
someone went for the look more than the
actual feel I
almost leave me alone get back here I
it's a slapping match you want
okay no you have to you have to just
rocket me in the face to win I don't
have uh-oh this is not good I knew that
was going to happen Okay let's get out
of here I'm out of here all right as
much as I want the match to end I don't
want it to end with me dying in a slap
fight fire all right I'm charging into a
fight with two bullets who wants a piece
oh I blew the bullets [__] oh [__] I
killed the dead
dude don't do that I mean that's got to
count really just double against my life
Rob is two kill points away from a kill
Victory Rob don't you come over here
with that claw rob you be careful I'm
cobbing baby
cobbing clob and Rob you guys want to go
to the clob clob hand I don't get it
nether do I
oh classic some dignity oh God the fire
I have one
point Neo Sean you have one point how
many suicides do you have I don't know a
bunch okay that's a good thing I have a
healthy amount of
suicides oh damn it the end of life a
man will be judged not by how many kills
agent I need to talk to you yeah uh-oh
this is not a fair match I'm going to
take
off hey what's
happening I have 17 kills by the way
yeah how do you think it's going end
when he has kill count of eight and you
have a kill count of 17 how do you think
it's going to end soon you were citing
to me the number of kills that popped up
but that was inaccurate and not an
indicator of the actual points what are
you talk well I just said I have 17
kills what do you that's actually
correct no Tom I'm talking about
earlier Rob's kill number popped up oh
no but he's got he actually has a lot of
points he doesn't have a lot of suicides
oh
God you dog you are you sure weren't you
guys just suiciding each other no he
doesn't suicide that's me that's that's
what Tom does yeah that's a Tom that's a
Tom M suicide come on Gillian Anderson
walk through walk through okay all right
yeah sure
ow okay I'm close nicely done Sean Stone
Cold oh no nicely done Tom Stone Cold
uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh uh-oh
[__] all right all right what is going
what is this gun
nonsense this the first time I've used a
gun run away I'm going to get a sh a
rocket launcher okay I'll come with you
oh kill count for mother
shits mother shits oh no
wait I lost one ofs oh that sounds count
it died 11 times all right what was the
scenario in which you guys let's do a
little video game mon confession while
we uh okay let's hear it what was the uh
scenario in which you guys play this the
most when what was the paint me a
picture I played this all through junior
year of high school okay uh like every
Friday night my buddies would come over
and we get Mama roses Pizza okay with
pepperoni and pineapple M yeah I
remember going over to Tom's house
junior year of high school you were way
younger than getting some maminos pizza
mam it was
delicious uh I played this game this
came out August 97 yes so that means I
was 12 years old you're just a baby and
I probably shouldn't have played this
game that young why were you playing
this when you were 12 obviously this has
had a NE when I was 12 I was playing
nice games like Mortal Kombat yeah
that's true with the green
blood no the for me this wasn't After
High School like oh After High School uh
sorry after the school day walk back to
my place drink Boku juice boxes eat
cheit and play golden eye like by
yourself or with a lot of people a lot
of people okay I remember playing this
in like the fifth grade I think that's
where I was and uh that was like last
week that was you graduated from fifth
grade last week but I remember um
everyone in the neighborhood would go to
like my friend's house and his older
brother was the best and I remember the
day that I beat his old brother cuz he
was unbeatable like in real life you
beat him beat
him his I got 20 kills no but when I
beat him he got so pissed he threw his
control on the on the ground wa was it
controller it could have been and that
was a day Rob became a man I said hey
guys I'm doing it with my
life oh come on is this it yeah please
oh my God I have 20 kills yeah finally
20 kills and yet you lost and I lost I
went seven points because I had 13
suicides harmless that is awful Chris
didn't kill me most frantic uh Rob
killed me twice I didn't kill myself
either Rob killed me twice but I killed
myself three killed Chris the most
double kill most professional because
professionals killed themselves 13 times
true yous oh my God I love how many that
how many have I won so far you've won
three all of them Rob all right we're
going to set up a new match it's going
to be Licensed to Kill we'll be starting
it up after this message from our
sponsors and yeah we're playing we're
playing a video game watch us play video
game wait which one I always forget
which character I am I want to be player
four guys I got body armor so we are
playing I guess they'll see pretty soon
they'll see what we're playing I
literally told them before the break
[__] yeah license pistol stack I didn't
say stack licensed pistol stack so then
we got in a discussion while you're gone
about the levels you play we're not
going to be able to play archives or
Caverns or Temple what else we we going
to play there something else cuz they're
they're not they can't play them with
four people for some reason that's
ridiculous I totally remember playing
four player Temple there is a way to do
it with like a game
shark um are you God game shark Tom I
have no knowledge of this but your
memory has proven to be better than mine
on matters golden ey so yeah it's it's
it's weird bunker is three player I
think yeah like there's some pretty good
you back him up on this Rob there's some
pretty definit no it's it's totally true
it's it's really weird cuz like Bunker's
a pretty big map who Temple yeah they
would they limited to three play three
not Temple not I meant uh [__] Egyptian
not temple temple four player this we've
got this set to 5 minutes so so how has
no one died yet
oh oh oh cuz Rob hasn't showed up oh my
God you're good man we need to get some
donuts in the office is there donuts why
are you just talking about Donuts all of
a sudden does anyone else really want a
donut now I talked about Donuts no damn
hey guys hey Bonito get us some
donuts just expensive Bonito just
scoffed he literally scoffed he SC yeah
he did guys do you think I can silence
you you can but it won't break oh you
can but it won't what Sean will you
freaking oh you just got shot in the
dome so badly me play a video game I am
playing the video game game called
life no no no uhoh uhoh uh-oh uhoh ooh
that was pretty
bloody I wish real Bond movies were just
Natalia trying to run around in a circle
while I was literally just standing
there
shooting I was not even running around
that would be a pretty good Bond movie
if there's just a bunch of idiots
running around slapping all right I'm
going to slap someone today
[__] oh no did I get shots yeah it was a
bullet it I was I was trying to shoot a
guy you got
brained snap look at that Sean two dead
people blazing it with two
kills I'm going to [__] slap someone so
hard a
cou oh you get cou I think I got no I
got I got both of you dang I know it was
a little cheap because I'm so so good
what if I said but I was announcing that
he was getting
[__] he you guys know what's weird is
holding
it what why you say something like that
why oh that is weird why you doing that
it's just a mirror version of it why you
doing that I'm holding I'm holding the
middle prong with my right hand now want
you want to feel something weird this
controller stop doing that you're making
me feel uncomfortable
no get slapped NOP welcome to a [__] I
shall not be slapped uh-oh look
alive this is you guys know that this is
basically what a real gun fight is cuz
you get shot once pretty much don't
worry I've got another gun here
somewhere I promise oh it also has no
bullets come here I want to slap your
face now it's cool damn it come here
Sean I am come on Sean
beam
[__] did you say Sean beam Bean with an
N okay good cuz you sounded it sounded
like you said he was like the cousin of
a a liquor
producer coug oh hello friend all right
I'm going to coug it up no no no no all
right CG it up this is so dirty it is
such a dirty thing to say cougal and I'm
out of oh no what does that mean is that
a thing I don't know what a coule is is
that a thing you do know now you're
embarrassed cuz you said it out loud no
okay it sounds really
filthy son no blur whenever I see Rob
he's always
unarmed my god oh that would have been
so cool I dodged every one of those it's
like the freaking fighting Neo over
here come on aut damn it the cougar
sucks do you know why because it's slow
cuz it's got a slow R of fire yeah it's
good for for when you're you know when I
just lost all three of you up oh that
was brutal hey how come the glass
respawns that's a little bizarre isn't
it it's cool for a human to respa but
but not for like a glass type of
situation I'm not doing so hot oh my
Lord oh my Lord oh my Lord what is that
14 to 77 my God all right now let's just
recall do you remember when I told you
the only mode I ever played was LIC to
kill
that's weird the only mode you ever
played look at it dude I literally
scored almost as much as all of you
combined how did that happen I'm telling
you this is validating my my golden eye
experience right here we should go
licensed caves now all right you want to
go into the oh damn it oh you
got swi oh my God this feels great [__]
I don't know how to swi going to have
one who's what wait who's what what what
player oh it's worth it I
for the satisfaction you can tell which
one
third oh God don't be holding down
sticks
by talking all that
crap I was but this time this match
that's my jam okay now Chris the shitty
thing oh my God this is a we do rematch
do rematch yeah I'm I'm now third so did
you what did you guys do you just had to
Swit you the wrong one you guys switch
four I switched two four
he swi I player three I'm why would you
switch I was player three four and three
Swit the parts yeah yeah that's what
we're doing all right which player were
you so Rob you're three I was I'm fourth
player I'm currently third so switch me
to Fourth put me back in third come me
in coach and then we should be should be
good wait Chris you're player three yes
okay well but who's player
six you're such a jerk oh my God six
wait a minute there's no who am I oh my
goodness okay and then who's who's who's
four me I'm four you're four is this you
for the fourth time yeah that's you it's
going is this You Yank can we please all
right we're good welcome to funky town
stop it population me okay level oh God
yeah I love basement we weren we just in
I guess we were not no not basement I
meant caves you do Temple Temple's great
caves I don't think I ever played caves
how did you how much did you play
throwing knives listen I'm telling you
we played the best mode Li to kill and
pistols and we only played a few Maps
one mode like two maps yeah we didn't
play caves that much not throwing that
God like remote mines yeah
remot remote AB sets them off start
thank you Tom AB at the same time yep
that's well yeah there's also a thing
you can switch to to set it off with
like a Detonator oh man how's that
controller look at this Boot Town guys I
can't see anything yeah there's a
there's a lot of glare in this level
yeah well basically in the set I'm
really glad that I have chosen to play
the bright blue character on this junky
situation oh my God I can't even see
play this map sometimes I don't know if
I can actually say Tom when I say I
never played it that's an exaggeration
but the major The Lion Share of my time
this game was spent in a very specific
oh what you freeze the game just froze
by for the best can you reset it I froze
it we can't actually see anything in
that because of
the studio lighting makes it impossible
to
see this is certif throwing two remote
mines and then dening them that's that's
going to freeze fre it's not always
going to freeze it wait let's a come on
you don't want to watch the full thing
but it's so tight ooh double O huh oh
what some cheat options we don't have
cheats we don't have any cheats on we
have DK mode and something else dumb we
do character we have paintball
oops kill sure sure level not do Temple
caves yeah Temple Temple's pretty dark
too Temple's really dark not as bad not
as bad as caves the old facility game
length we'll do 20
minutes un unlimited unimited weapons
remote mines because we could actually
do throwing knives which is kind of fun
we will do those all right you guys
ready wait no let's only do let's only
do choose character fair enough fa
enough characters we already do all the
name
characters
Natalia who chose Zenia me Tom someone
want to be Jaws he is the funniest
looking thing in the whole
world Michigan I'm going back to sha
Bean um
um okay is that it that's it we're
rocking activate activate take me to
funky
town I got an awesome hat toilet kill
the guy with the awesome hat oh [__]
kill awesome hat
guy God damn it [__] it both of
you
oh oh no wait give me a sec n that's
cool this is being a
d what a dag he's being a d yeah Chris
you're being a real bag of d right now
oh everything's cool when Chris is
terrible at the game but then when he
starts running train on your asses you
start complaining what a bu of Baby W I
just don't like it when you use the
phrase run I know it's a terrible phras
Running Train is kind of a DE to slap
me you to death while you had Ana I'm
going to all day oh that was did you
really just say you're running train I
don't know is that a is that a good
thing do you know what that means what
does that mean I don't know if it's in
your mind Tom has something to do with
human centipede it's Tom what does it
mean it's it's
it's I I don't want to explain what this
mean what is Running Train everybody
everybody knows is that like dinging
dong is that like a hobo term for like
trying to like get on a train I would
have killed you sooner but I was
literally tapping this stupid shitty
trigger button for like let's do okay
let's do a uh hot or cold attempt to
guess Running Train does it does it have
to do with a
penis yes okay so H okay okay that is
hot does it have to do with putting a
penis into a place it shouldn't be ah am
I getting warmer or
cold I mean I don't want you to assign
like a value judgment what well that
would be a value
judgment Rob how did you use this
controller dude it's awful it's the
worst it's the worst thing just pretend
it's something
else
I'm curious if the wait how these C
buttons got switched for me I'm not
Twisted someone said I'm one twisted so
yeah you're a little twist yeah well cuz
you're talking about running train all
day I didn't bring that up
you all right okay okay wait this is
inverted is that possible it's always
inverted it was always inverted it was
you all along it was inside of you all
along you were the monster all along Rob
you're really Godzilla hey I thought we
were doing remote m
I like really go pick up some remote
mines and then we'll have we'll be doing
remote mines or just call come and walk
into my hallway of
death a bad not a hallway to me hang out
in it's a cool place where everybody to
die shamefully
shamefully all right I'm going to Chuck
the hell out of some remote homies
someone's on
me [__] why can't I detonate them while
I'm dying CU you're big you're dead oh
well I'm not dead until the blood
completely covers my eyes no yes dude I
almost want to switch back medical
school I haven't but I think that's how
it
works oh haven't gotten a bu bust out
somebody should go to the bathroom and
make sure the person in the bathroom
dies uhoh well maybe they're just
running train in peace listen they just
want to go R find a place to run did
more than one person run to the bathroom
bathroom is the worst place means I I
don't know it sounds it sounds I don't
want to talk about it I really don't
know I swear to God does the twitch chat
know what run train means I feel like we
need to get to the we need we need to
know people need to be educated oh oh
that was I am blowing it around I'm just
I just
ran yeah you saw a fight breaking out
you ran train out of
there wait oh God it's OV like what's
your name Michigan
mil I don't know the people who are lame
like
mishin listen just because they were a
bureaucrat and not Jonathan Bond oh [__]
I think his real name was James yeah
James Bon it's a l known
fact everyone called him Jonathan he
doesn't just spell out or say his name
every movie little known fact James is
not short for Jonathan this is a weird
moment G Jonathan
Bond the name
stepped out the wrong direction
bro you do this is not going well
this uhoh hey hold your fire yeah never
mind oh
[__] goddamn license to kill this is not
what I never playy here's a question how
good would you have to be at karate for
your karate chops to actually make this
kind of sound
why is Chris so good at this cuz it's
literally all I played well not
literally it's 95% of what I played so
weird oh it's like a whole new
world okay can I go back and I'm good at
the first at getting the first shot
where's the armor is the [__] one
that you get cuz they're like I don't
[__] know hey guys it's liced account
listen I just want you to know I wasn't
discriminating I killed you all almost
exactly the same amount of times a lot
that's pretty good that's so nice each
what a guy so apparently most
professional there's a reason I want to
go go to control Style I want to see
something oh God so Urban Dictionary
apparently has quite the answer
according to Blackberry hibiscus yeah uh
but he doesn't say what it is come on
there's two other ones yeah and then
there's a underground child runaway
Highway like in the soul asy is that you
your third that's not me I was going to
switch it for Tom while he wasn't
looking I was looking did anyone
detonate a single remote mine in that
not one grenade launchers in Temple prox
mines why doesn't anyone post we did
proximity mines already grenade lach
kill grenade launchers in the temple
grenade launchers grade launchers in the
temple temple oh but the Temple's so
dark why don't people in the chat
actually post what Running Train means
cuz I don't want to say it but I think
it's really vulgar it's probably going
to be something real basic like putting
your junk in a jar of peanut butter
change it to Temple oh my goodness Sean
select grenade launchers you are not
only bad at this game you're bad at the
menu grenades grenade launchers please
man so you guys can't just
refer oh they'd be banned from the chat
is it because of YouTube it's probably
because of Google would ban them Tom can
we just give it up I know you love to
reference horrible Urban Dictionary
stuff on my live stream whenever I
invite you on bring that grenade
launcher I'm this I I said that the
phrase is this a license yeah yeah
license to what kill oh cool ill it's
Licensed to Ill
oh but seriously what does Running Train
mean this is greatest mystery of our ER
it means
dominating here we go sure in that
context is what it meant it's a slly
term there's a lot of and another from
downtown a this controller is all all
weird that's that damn controller
although although you uh you did win
last time with that controller it's
something's up something's up with that
controller man I think people in the
chat are slowly going to Urban
Dictionary and seeing what it says a and
and coming back
horrified I forgot how dumb this grenade
launcher looks yeah it's really damn it
it's so silly looking it's one of the
dumbest looking guns I can't this is not
a dark level by the way let's just noce
that who's up next I'm going to roll
here here we go yeah I think yeah I
think noodle legs is what I was going to
say the
definition Tom repeat it now noodle you
can read what noodle legs is saying oh
no oh no oh that's not it's not it's not
like a nice term or anything it's kind
of really gross like what is this oh my
God armag over here I'm out of here
noodle legs noodle legs oh
gross this is why I don't want to say it
I don't know why you guys were talking
about running
train see listen not everything that has
slang in the pornography Universe does
not have other meanings that are not
porn uh disagree I I'm Tom your
knowledge of porn slang is shocking to
me
what is going on here it is really
shocking it is uh not only your
knowledge of but you're willing to
reference multiple times I'm going to be
honest guys whenever possible I'm going
to be honest it was all fun in games
until I read what it meant and now I
wish we weren't talking about it anymore
I think it's going to be the welcome to
where I am Sean I wish we hadn't been
talking about it for the past 10 minutes
yeah all right let's change the subject
oh my Lord someone lobed that right over
my shoulder into the front of my face
wow he must be really good huh was that
you must be a very talented individual a
really good shot probably very smart and
handsome as well his parents probably
really love him oh wow this is this is
going really
well oh why is it wait now I'm not
anymore dude I swear to God I used to be
ined and I'm not ined I swear it
switched I'm not the only one then no
you're totally right that's saying
earlier wased yeah it totally was I
don't know how that happened must have
been when it
froze yeah when it froze some short
circuit
yeah diverted yeah diverted it divert
Tom what does diverting mean in a
forense uh like in a pornog on a porn
set if someone was like we're doing the
diversion scene what does it what's when
you put it in a jar of peanut
butter oh no I just Ked myself this is
apparently your big thing did I get a
kill for any of those murders ah guys
I'm real bad at Golden
Eye it's okay Sean I not now Tom Running
Train msh That's
not fine Tom The Human Centipede
msh whoa oh who's got negative one who
does have negative one I don't know I
hope not me no not me not Sean I like
how that's what the stats say you said
it as like a like a taunting thing but
no one knew the
answer wait who's on is someone on top
of me all right I'm going to try to use
the middle Tom no
Tom is someone I don't know Tom are you
doing the dersion scene oh why don't you
get dead Tom let's drop Tri we're going
to need to get this dersion scene I
don't like the grenade launcher did I
just kill you yeah you did what is is
Divergence a book is that like a book
series Divergent not yeah yes it is okay
is it good no it is beloved by many is
it good I don't know I I had a friend or
two said it was awesome but I don't
trust him at all I like things that you
know what I'm reading now atas Shrugged
cool which is totally a book about
certain things isn't that a book about
Bioshock yeah Bioshock is based on
basic Bioshock is so much more
fun yeah cuz at the shrug doesn't have
the plasmids no it doesn't have plasmids
yet maybe maybe I'm only like halfway
through St directly on that yeah I did I
really
did
[__]
that's the alarm people quick you guys
can get 17 kills and
win that's how you have 17 kills oh no
I'm running train on the Divergent books
right now just one after the other I'm
go that's what horsey said that works uh
negative one was your finishing score
talk about it that's pretty good I want
to talk about it most deadly most
professional if you wouldn't have played
you
would that's true all right all right
fin round I'll let you guys choose
obviously if it's one if it's Licensed
to Kill I dominate you all shamelessly
so if you want to switch it to something
else yeah let's switch it go ahead why
don't we do uh teams no no oh yeah
that's stupid idea do that proximity Min
a real Rob idea yeah classic Rob move
we're going to do proximity mines we
already didx team fun we can do it again
whatever your choice or we can just go
out oh these things come on we got to
hit some of this up yeah all right slow
animation sounds awful DK mode paintball
mode uh oh turbo mode turbo no radar no
radar fast animation radar not fast
animation that's going to get no this is
Bonkers it's it's going to explode slow
animation is actually really funny
though yeah it's good no radar okay
whatever you don't want to do SL cheat
multiplayer all right proximity M
cheaters 5 minutes
complex okay not yeah
I am Invincible go ahead Sean yeah just
go ahead yeah last match you earned it
you earned the handicap I got negative
one last time oh you doing it all right
you doing jaw I'll go for uh was it
Valentine Valentine here we go you guys
ready for this let's do it animation is
not only for cut scenes there actually
is a way to oh my God instantly terrible
oh
god oh no in my face oh I'm nauseous oh
is it still on one still on Licensed to
Kill
on turbo mode license to kill this is a
bad idea guys I can't even pick up
ammunition yeah why can't I pick up
proximity mines I know it doesn't I'm
actually like literally walking over
this n that's the one thing I want to
pick up is proximity mines though I
don't know I don't know what to tell you
oh wait who is this horrible demon
running around
upstairs look at all you horrible demons
oh that's right paintball mode oh my God
oh my goodness you all are hideous look
at all the colors all right I oh you got
slapped oh my god you're an abomination
of nature is it that I'm a tiny man with
a big head wait somebody should not
shoot me I'm going to put okay player
lower left don't shoot me yeah I don't
know about that don't shoot me I'm not
the hidey hole look at how gross I
look really kill me was odd job who do
you think it I really wanted everyone to
see how close how weird Jaws cuz Jaws is
the weirdest looking Sean is just trying
to salvage any dignity he can by that's
not how you Sal no Jos has the most mess
up face
does you will never catch me also I took
my hand off crime I raised my right hand
I was sh guys your how come we can't
pick up the mines oh I don't know must
be one of those cheats we put on we
can't pick up up the cheats what done it
oh maybe you can't do it with paintball
mode or I don't know no it's not
paintball mode it's probably faster than
turbo probably turbo Turbo is what ruins
it I'm guessing that's fine it's worth
it what
happened Max so from the back room
infinite Amo means um ammo means you
cannot pick up the boxes which are where
the mines
are can I just run right in front of
you BL BL I just sprinted right you guys
are getting blaed all over town [__] I
got BL that I got BL no I got blaed now
the blapper is the BL e Urban Dictionary
that Urban Dictionary yeah that's could
to be really gross also yeah and then
look up Running Train no don't look it
up yeah you kind of ruined my wow you
definitely got odd jobed you shot
directly over his head I saw that go
down what's wrong with a he's going to
have a big old asterisk next to this one
no way odd job hey it's cheat
multiplayer it's fine it's cheat
multiplayer my cheat is that I'm using
odd
job oh my goodness I just turned around
and there was gunfire coming from below
me wa my waist must have been a w wo wo
whoo whoa whoa scly take it easy fing
odd job what you can't blame all your
ills on odd job you pretty much can man
yeah no OD job is
largely
is exactly not that actually he's
largely innocent of most of the terrible
things that ever happened in history
that's true oh I'm going to get you here
comes a job you giant
jerk oh not of my w you knew what was
coming I knew it I I respect that about
you but I hate
you getting really
personal
oh no
oh the cheat has definitely neutralized
my advantage in license to Kill I I on
Hot Roll most definitely what was your
what is what what sheat this fast one
the turbo one turbo mode is really
messing me up oh I remember about fast
animation it's like your body's just die
like hit the ground really
quick which is a fantastic idea
yeah oh I'm moving to fast I'm moving
too
fast losing control oh my god seriously
was giving me a headache yeah I'm a
little
nauseous oh I sped by someone definitely
done that a few
times I'll get you on the next
lap get back oh Natalia oh you did ah
you died whatever here we go the
opposite this is the first time I've
seen you the whole
time seriously classic Jaws God damn it
invert no I was doing the I was doing
the aim oh we know what did I tell you
about aiming Chris you were aiming too
no I wasn't I was using the C buttons
that's aing hit the fire
alarm damn it one more kill oh that put
me in first hey look you guys tied for
victory tied great work GG everybody gg
gg mostly harmless I got nothing this is
the third time I've got most where's
yeah what the hell is that hey how come
I got where's the ammo on infinite ammo
and where's the armor license to kill it
just enses your native bafflement with
how to play this game
well a and with that cheat debacle I
think we're going to wrap this up uh
thank you guys for playing golden I
double zero and then a seven at the end
of it thank you guys for watching uh
multiple players it's been uh fun to do
some old games in video game history
month we did tow jamer last week golden
eye this week if you have any
suggestions for what to do next week
send them to me at CT waters on Twitter
that's CT W RS and uh maybe we'll get uh
get some of your suggestions going can
we play Lemmings send it to me on
Twitter Tom also uh look at all those
modes I totally wrote a story about why
told J should come back so it piggy
backs off of your thing that's true so
people should read that cuz to needs to
come back
we need more tojam Earl in our lives and
uh I think we can all agree about that
yeah uh tomorrow morning 11:00 a.m.
Shawn method i'mna get you Sean Bean
never mind he's just being a weirdo uh
actually we do have some Wolfenstein
review is posting today today yeah 900
p.m. Pacific so that's just in 6 hours
that'll be live on the site so come back
and check that transistor is also a
reviews posting for that as well
tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow morning so
big reviews we're gonna have both those
games or we're going to have Wolfenstein
on the lobby tomorrow if you want to
check it out that's at 2: p.m. tomorrow
that's all that's hey I'll see you later
everybody everybody waave to wait to the
folks at home all
right